this is the political idea of
I think you know that party from Thierry Baudet
baudet is the founder of forum
and previously wrote that IE wants to cause some commotion
sir
what are you wearing again
the overwhelming part of the population
votes for this too
Want this
Want all those fucking windmills and Want all those immigrants
priceless houses
and Want those suckers in the EU who decide everything
the party wants lockdowns through the law as during Corona
banning and tackling climate change
they think that is nonsense
The Netherlands must leave the European Union
and in the North Sea would be 1 Groot
new airport
and in Groningen
gas must be removed from the ground again
okay and what's about youth forum
Want 1 ban on information about it
being transgender at school and on children's television
andgeslachtsveranderende operations
orhormoonbehandelingen under the age of eighteen
then about VMBO
forum Wants you to get fewer general subjects
and more subjects that train you to 1 practical profession